like d4 but i want more info on the
giant chest
no is that
yeah
what time where do we have to be
um i think it's 1 p.m
at the park that's doable
yeah it's terrible isn't it yeah
okay are we gonna see knight f3 knight
c3
what do you predict i think knight f3
well he's been playing the catalan
recently
so is he gonna gonna stick with it or
try to surprise anish
and play in a move that's not g3 yeah
there comes the knight
knight to c3
and kiri
will have to make up his mind he's of
course capable of playing anything
favorites are the ragozin or the semi
tarash
and he's
he's probably slightly surprised by
knight c3s g3 is what carlson has been
playing in this tournament and also what
he played
in vikanze against anish
i reckon it's going to be a samutarus
that seems to be all the rage these days
but uh rogozin is a good choice
it's an excellent move brings the bishop
out pins the knight prepares castling
what more could he want from him
yeah
what is the i mean i saw a lot of the
top players on the tour were kind of
reacting to that uh bishop before with
queen a4 check
seems to be quite trendy at the minute
and
you like this move queen a4 or do you
think it's actually better to capture
the pawn in the middle or develop the
bishop
they're all the same really gives an
advantage
so you just look for directions that are
a little fresh in here recently it's
been a trend here maybe they hope to win
the bishop but normally black
parries this check with knight c6
um
but anish is not in the mood and as you
correctly predicted he goes for pawn to
c5
when the line that everybody is playing
now is cd5 cd4
which here is a very direct attempt to
force the issue geary also does like
this line with knight takes d5 the more
the more classical simi tarash
but c takes d4 is so direct
yeah that's hard to resist and there he
goes
you know
you're big city people from bergen you
look down on stavanger
no it's a big city people from london
and so to me like bergen is like village
village town
but um no city apparently round one
and uh yeah so according to aubien you
were two hundred thousand out
two hundred and seventy thousand people
so yeah people in the world london is
bigger london is bigger than norway yeah
bishop to g5
bishop to e7
e3 is usually played
short castles and then white has a
choice move repetition well we will go
back to that game when the armageddon
kicks off it seems like he hasn't
prepared this
exact scenario for today which
is
a mild surprise and maybe he's trying to
force the issue with this bishop f6 to
a
slightly better safe position especially
if six knight d5 does look slightly
slightly better for white
yes okay so knight takes pawn yeah
that's the only sense will move if not
you don't give up
should take that night
and uh
that's very very surprising and we have
to we we dismissed that yeah i suggested
it
i suggested it just because you know
that's my job to suggest
yeah
and i wish i completely
oh this looks bespoke
what's he doing hang on you suggested
hit g4 this is shocking
switching on the engine and yeah it says
bishop b3 first move
240 for white 240 should b3 just
covering the d1 square g4 it also likes
220 h4
also plus two
no just it just looks very bad because
the black rooks can't get active in time
and a wide attack on the king's side
especially with opposite colored bishops
should frankly just win so i'm
really really surprised by this decision
well he's he's in a fantastic position
here
and uh well we're expecting magnus
probably to wrap up the game
i think in within 20 moves that's not
which sounds like a lot of moves but
actually
this is very scary spot for anish he's a
very resilient defender let's see if he
manages to organize something that bad
looks
it looks beyond repair
totally uh there's no way that he can do
anything on those light squares
and
if he's unable to coordinate both of his
rooks i just didn't see a chance for the
dutchman
as uh we saw him trade two rooks for the
queen but the problem is his light
squares are very very weak and just
looking at this position
the big question here is can white
simply not just play g5 g5 option
probably but decide it's not needed
anish does not want to give up the b7
pawn
goes rook to e7 preparing e5 okay but
now g5 should be even stronger
i think that's going to happen 94.
yeah g5 on the board
he has lots of choice i i reckon he's
going to go pawn takes pawn what do you
think
no i think it's going to spot queen f5
we should have a bet
i reckon
pawn takes queen f5
i wonder
what everyone at home is thinking as
well
pawn takes knight takes queen f5 the
problem is is that there's lots of
choice so he is burning a little bit of
time on the clock but still 15 minutes
to navigate the rest of the game is a
lot of time
it won't get increment until move 40 for
which he gets a 10 second move increment
per move
world champion
deep thought
yeah now i'm looking at his body
language i'm thinking
you're on to something queen of five
looks like he smells something she's
just trying to verify it yeah he looks
like
he's a tiger about to pounce
they're
calculating it away because if queen
takes this typical trick
so it really does put the maximum amount
of pressure on the black position
that has to be yeah this is the only
move right because
oh he's made a move oh he took with the
knight
bishop f6
only move
to stay in the game and only a move 22
as well so again you have to remember
the players are not playing with
increment until they reach move 40.
yep that's uh bishop takes knight forced
the second armageddon game between
wesley and vichy anish has been
struggling now for a while but this
actually is starting to look quite dire
didn't push deep on but just calmly
collect some pawns
which also looks plenty good enough
black
still struggles to
anish would simply just skip up
yeah rook h6 but still goes back to b3
for f6 trying to
free the other rook
but that's still
still the old plant of pushing the e
pawn
it just looks
fairly hopeless
carlson has played bishop b3 no
experiments just put the bishop
on a square where it's covered by the
pawn
gear is going for
desperate last counter attack here with
his g pawn but it's frankly
not attacking much
and guess he wants g3
right
but okay even if he gets that say for
instance white just ignores it
resist this pawn push yeah that pawn
push is just uh
just dart too direct and too beautiful
most of us are just brutes looking at
this i wonder when the e pawn
will start
it will it will make it
it's a bit
for freedom at one point
no no yeah
let me put the queen here just a little
closer around that you have to go to the
edge of the board
there will still be pieces now if you
want to start the game with one knight
f3 you can but you can go backwards
yeah so we're going to see i mean the
action starts at 1 p.m i'll be there at
12th just to make sure
i don't miss anything
yeah i
i'm looking forward to it and uh well
yeah you got your wish
what was my wish your wish was to see
the airborne
move
and that's true
yeah i think you're just quibbling over
the details but now gary should go t3
and if the pawn gets taken boom
come back
yeah it feels like it's a broken record
on repeats just when you think you're
out of it
back in again but the knight on f7
oh yeah oh well
the world champion will be very very
happy
yeah
no but they do know but i've seen them
also attacked together but they placed
themselves up and we have a hand designs
and views
soon enough and uh that's it the world
champion picks up his second classical
win and that's another three points yes